on lectures in history emory university
professor felix harcourt teaches a class
on how conspiracy theories about ufos
have shaped american culture he begins
in the late 1940s and describes how
public opinion about extraterrestrials
changed over the course of the 20th
century often paralleling societal
anxieties this class is about an hour
and 15 minutes
let's start with a question that i'm
sure nobody will have
any problem having their answer recorded
for television for
show of hands how many people believe
alien life exists
yeah pretty decent number of people i'm
gonna throw in there as well
but i think so stephen hawking thinks so
in a giant universe there is distinctly
a probability that somewhere alien life
has evolved and uh you know
probably looks pretty different from us
but it might be out there
slightly different question
how many of us believe that aliens have
visited earth
sergio the only man with the strength of
his convictions
i appreciate that
um
so here's a question
is the idea that aliens have visited
earth
in and of itself
a conspiracy theory
i don't believe that no why not well i
mean if you take into uh
consideration the fact that we're trying
to go to mars we would technically be
alien life there so the fact that
another life form say that has
become intelligent enough to do space
travel visits another planet isn't
really a conspiracy theory
seems fair i mean i guess it depends on
how you define the scope of like a
conspiracy theory because
it takes an entire species more or less
collaborating together to to land
themselves on another planet so there's
an entire race working together
considered a conspiracy
i wouldn't really think so yeah it seems
reasonable right it seems a little odd
to indict the entire planet of
wherever for wanting to come and visit
and even if we are going to say arguably
maybe we could consider it a conspiracy
theory it's a conspiracy of
aliens in and of themselves right
which is not what we tend to talk about
when we talk about ufo conspiracy
theories when we talk about alien
conspiracy theories those are theories
that include an element of human
complicity uh usually of government
complicity
and these ideas that there are not only
aliens visiting earth
but that the state is in some way
involved with those visits
is a really prominent conspiracy theory
it's not really one conspiracy it's a
multitude of conspiracy theories
and
like uh the kennedy conspiracism that we
were talking about last week
to just stand here and name
every ufo conspiracy theory would take
much longer than we have in this class
so tragically we will not be talking
about the fact that nasa is hiding the
existence of the planet nibiru
tragically we will not be talking about
the fact that we are in secret contact
with andromeda and
uh part of a vast intergalactic war
and tragically we will not be talking
about the fact that the earth is hollow
and is filled with interstellar beings
who may or may not have been allied with
the nazis in world war ii depending on
who you ask
and i see a couple of kind of smiles
at those ideas right which is
understandable
but these are real ideas that real
people
fiercely and fully believe in
and we should be clear before we dig
into this too much as bridget brown
makes clear in that reading that you did
for today
not everybody who believes in ufos
believes in ufo conspiracy theories
and even amongst those who do believe in
ufo conspiracy theories there is a wide
variation all right
we keep coming back to this idea of a
fringe conspiracism and a center
conspiracism and that's very much
evident within these ufo conspiracy
theories
it's worth thinking about right that
these ufo conspiracy theories are
widely treated as something laughable
in fact serious discussion of them is
really an effective cultural taboo
we've talked about the labeling of
something as conspiracy as a distancing
measure
alien conspiracy theories are possibly
one of the most evident examples
of the distancing of conspiracist belief
from acceptable discourse
and yet at the same time even as they're
treated as laughable as riseable
they're some of the most widely believed
conspiracy theories
if we go back to the 60s
gallup polls find
96 percent of americans had heard of
ufos
46 percent believed that they were real
1973
57 believe
that ufos are real
by the 90s
71 percent believe the government is at
least hiding information about ufos
they may or may not be real
but there's definitely more going on
there
than the government is letting us know
and those numbers remain
relatively stable
a 2015 ipsos poll
showed that
56 percent
believed that ufos are real
45 percent believe that aliens have
actually landed and visited earth
on top of that
to put that in context
right 56 believe ufos are real
in that same survey
57
said that the big bang theory was real
this is very much a widely held belief
that is very mainstream at least the
idea that something is going on with
ufos
even if we narrow it into a specific
example like roswell
a majority of americans will repeatedly
say that they are at the very least
unsure
whether or not a flying saucer crashed
in roswell new mexico
and so we have this odd disconnect right
between
this very very mainstream idea this
majority idea
and yet the way that it's treated within
our political and cultural discourse
it's also not an idea that's new at all
the idea that
weird lights or objects in the sky is
something to be concerned about is
nothing new
but then if you are a surf in
13th century europe
what are you going to think that
floating lights in the sky might be is
it going to be aliens
witches
witches
omens of doom
any other guesses
god right god
devils
uh witches
omens
overwhelmingly a supernatural
explanation
and it's not really until we start to
see that kind of enlightenment
rationalism supplant these ideas of
divine providence
that we move from kind of supernatural
to scientific explanations for these
unexplained phenomena
although even then we need to be careful
about drawing too wide of a divide
between those two as we're going to see
the two ideas the supernatural and
scientific are going to remain pretty
thoroughly intertwined
matthew
we've got uh 11 of people here we think
ufos are real but don't think aliens
have visited earth
and i was wondering
you know ufo is just an unidentified
flying object
like where's the boundary there
unidentified according to who like there
are a lot of things i can't identify in
the sky
but i assume somebody can
this is true this is true um
yeah the ipsos polls the wording isn't
great
the way that the obsess poll explains
that is
uh not that there's an 11 difference
between
those who believe ufos are an
extraterrestrial a phenomenon right what
gets
uh commonly referred to as the
extraterrestrial hypothesis that ufos
are real and are
alien related the 11 difference is 56
believe ufos are real
uh 11 fewer believe that some of those
ufos have landed and that we have had
contact with the aliens um that's that's
the differential that's playing out
there
the differential between
something else going on right is that 56
going up to 71
from the 90s the idea that there is
something going on with this question
and that idea that there is something
going on has a long history right this
uh concern over extraterrestrial contact
has a long history
if we go back to
1835
the new york newspaper the sun
garners major attention
in reporting that an astronomer has
found life on the moon
um life in the shape of a series of
humanoid bat people
turns out unsurprisingly that it's a
hoax
i'm sorry to disappoint anybody who's
hoping the bat people are really living
on the moon
but it points us to the ideas that are
already percolating around in the 19th
century
that gets really evident in the late
19th century
in 1891 when thomas blott
alleges that a man from mars appeared in
the kitchen of his rural home
and fully endorsed
late 19th century democratic socialist
utopianism
which was nice for thomas blott to hear
since he was already a believer in such
things
or
in 1896 1897
where you see a series of
unexplained airships seen in the skies
over the west coast
and there's a really interesting variety
of stories that come out about these
airships
some of them claim that they see
humanoid beings inside pedaling to make
it go
which if that is a spaceship that is a
lot of pedaling
some allegedly call out to the airship
as it goes over and the airship calls
back down to say that they are from mars
right even in the 19th century people
are very fixated on the idea of life on
from mars
but there's these ideas right that
there is this long history this long
concern about
contact with extraterrestrial life and
extraterrestrial life visiting us here
on earth
but when we talk about modern ufo
conspiracism
what we're really talking about is the
post-world war ii era
and these conspiracies paint an
alternative history of america
from the cold war to the present
what we might call
ethno-sociologies
of extraterrestrial conspiracism
that reflect
very terrestrial concerns about agency
about state power
about disempowerment and
depersonalization
about ideas of expertise and authority
and especially of ideas of skepticism
about expertise and authority and about
narratives of progress whether social or
scientific
and that modern ufo phenomenon really
gets kick-started um after world war ii
in 1947
by this gentleman kenneth arnold
people had seen pilots had seen
unidentified phenomena during world war
ii um
they get commonly referred to as foo
fighters which is actually where the
band's name comes from
but it's not until
kenneth arnold's sighting
in late june of 1947 of what he
describes to
newspapers as flying discs
what gets widely reported as flying
sources
that the modern ufo phenomenon begins
and it spreads very very quickly
over the july 4th holiday that year
thousands of men and women contact
authorities
to report more than
850 sightings of ufos
that's never been paralleled since
there's never been such a frenzy of ufo
sightings as there was over independence
holiday
in 1947. although sightings remain
fairly common through to the early 1950s
right and you get um pictures like this
from new jersey from 1952
alleging uh you know a sighting of an
unidentified flying object
and unsurprisingly
you see a variety of efforts to try to
explain this phenomenon
two of the most influential voices in
that process
are frank scully
and donald kehoe
scully
was a writer for variety magazine
who publishes behind the flying sources
in 1950
where he really focuses in
on the story of flying sources that
crash in the american southwest
and where did that crash take place
not roswell but thank you for falling
into my easy trap
in fact scully says that they crash in
aztec new mexico
neither scully nor kehoe ever mentioned
roswell
and we're going to talk a little bit
later about why that is
but scully says sources crash in aztec
and not only do sources crash scully
says
but bodies are found
three to four foot tall alien beings
really cementing um
the modern idea of the little green man
comes out of scully's books
he also claims that the sources come not
from mars
but from venus
and the 1950s are really kind of a key
time in
a mars venus battle over where these
flying sources come from
scully loses
popularity after 1952
because true magazine
publishes an extensive article debunking
his entire book
pointing out the fact that
most of or really all of scully's
sources are professional con men
and really just spending page after page
making fun of scully for believing the
con men and even making fun of how
terrible frank scully's writing is it's
a really mean article um
and it destroys scully's credibility
but scully's ideas are going to have a
really long shelf life and actually just
in recent years
there's been an uptick in people trying
to
attract some of the roswell tourism away
over to aztec and publishing new books
saying that scully was right and sources
really did crash in aztec new mexico
a little bit more kind of credible at
least at the time than scully is donald
kehoe
a retired officer from the marine corps
who writes three
very popular books
the flying sources are real which is
released in 1950
flying sources from outer space which
comes out in 1953
and the flying saucer conspiracy
in 1955
and kehoe
reports
conversations and interviews that he's
purportedly had with
air force officers and specifically air
force intelligence officers
to try and substantiate his warnings
that first of all
ufos are real and military pilots are
encountering them on a semi-regular
basis
second of all
he thinks there's a very good chance
that the aliens have set up a mothership
in orbit of earth and the ufos are
coming from that mothership rather than
all the way from another planet
and thirdly that
these ufos are most likely from mars
right he's he's not a venus fan he's
back on the mars train
and what's interesting about kiko
is that he does see a conspiracy
he does see a conspiracy by the military
to cover up the reality that earth is
being visited by these flying sources
but
he doesn't blame them for doing so
for kehoe
what he calls the silence group
is acting out of a desire to protect
national security
and a desire to prevent public hysteria
and while he disagrees with that
decision
he sees it as a matter of reasonable
disagreement
he doesn't see nefarious motives at work
and that is
an idea that is going to change
significantly
over the 60s and especially coming out
of the 70s into the 80s
but it's really easy at the time to see
the impact of writers like kehoe
who see
a conspiracy of silence but not
necessarily a nefarious conspiracy of
silence
right 1952
that same year that true magazine is
debunking scully
life magazine
leads with
a
big front cover splash of marilyn monroe
and the headline there is a case for
interplanetary sources
and life comes down hard in that issue
to say that they think something
probably is going on with ufos
less concerned with kind of credibility
but no less influential in putting these
ideas into the american consciousness
is the glut of alien invasion films in
the 1950s
of course the classic invasion of the
body snatches
but also invasion of the saucer men
invaders from mars killers from space
earth versus the flying sources and more
and there's a couple of interesting
elements to be brought out from these
films
not the least of which is a lot of them
deal with aliens either taking control
of humans minds
or of replacing them entirely with
simulacra with look-alikes
and given that these are coming out
mid to late 50s
what other fears have we been talking
about that that kind of coincides with
marissa
like um communism that was spreading
into like the us government and
everything yeah certainly communist
infiltration
yeah carolyn
brainwashing of korean pows brainwashing
good right this is
very much playing on two simultaneous
fears bubbling up in the 1950s not just
that the communists are infiltrating but
the communists are infiltrating through
this kind of mind control ideas um and
pairing that with this fear of
extraterrestrial threat as well
and it really is an extraterrestrial
threat
these films overwhelmingly buy in to
a donald kehoe style view of what's
happening the threat is purely
extraterrestrial it is not human and in
fact most of these films
rather than the state being complicit or
suspect
government agents particularly military
agents are the heroes they're the ones
saving us from this extraterrestrial
threat
so you have yeah evil um what is like
the thought behind the motives of the
aliens to
like be a threat like to attack um us
like is there a thought of like why
they're doing that yeah the kind of the
why of the conspiracy and attack um
there isn't really a single unifying
idea in the 50s um
other than
domination right the the the plan is
always to conquer the world
uh why they want to conquer the world is
open for interpretation is it because
their own planet is dying
is it because they want to kind of make
us into slaves
there's a pretty wide latitude there but
yeah good question
so we see this kind of key host style um
opposite of paranoia at work to some
extent right anybody remember our word
for opposite of paranoia
no security
yeah but not quite right security is
kind of the middle line hope indifferent
yeah not quite
no
what do you call it when a conspiracy is
acting for your good not against you
anybody remember that
no
not paranoia but pro-noyer
this is very much an example of pronoid
conspiracy thinking
and that's evident in um another kind of
thread of
extraterrestrial phenomena that emerges
in the 50s
which is an increasing number of people
who claim that not only have they seen
ufos
but that they have been contacted by
aliens
and this is really kicked off
by a man called georgia damsky
he's the first contactee to publish a
book length account of his experience in
1953
and adamski
contradicts virtually everything that
has come before him
he says that
they're not from mars they're from venus
and if scully's right about them being
from venus he's wrong about them being
short he says they're about five foot
six
they're humanoid and they're very
beautiful
and adamski also says that they are not
a threat
he says the coming was friendly
now adamski is going to lose kind of
popular support in the 60s
after he claims that he will be leaving
any day now for an interplanetary
conference on saturn
and somehow never quite makes his
appointment for that
but
his ideas his narrative that there are
these friendly visitors has very much
caught on
and throughout the 1950s
you see this
series of encounters with
extraterrestrial beings
who have seemingly come to warn humanity
about our war-like nature to warn us
that nuclear weapons will destroy us all
a very pure distillation of common cold
war fears at the time
cold warfare is also bearing no small
resemblance to the 1951 film the day the
earth stood still which is basically the
exact same plot adamski recounts two
years later
but nobody really picked sidamsky off on
this at the time
so there's still this pro noyer at work
in the early 50s right this idea that
yes
the government might be lying to us but
they're doing it for our own good or yes
aliens are visiting
but they're doing it for our own good
that increasingly is going to take a
darker turn
as we move out of the 50s into the 60s
and you start to see not least the
government's motives and its methods
become much darker in hiding the truth
and that's especially going to become
symbolized by the idea of the men in
black
and the men in black is an idea
that is really
[Music]
kind of more or less put into play by an
author called grey barker
and grey bark is an interesting guy
barker makes a pretty good living
publishing books about supposedly true
ufo encounters
but two friends
privately calls flying saucers a bucket
of [ __ ]
so very much uh capitalizing on this
trend
but he's going to more or less launch
this idea of the men in black in his
1956 book they knew too much about
flying saucers
a book that's based on the experiences
of a factory clerk from connecticut a
man called albert bender
who claimed that
three men in black suits
had approached him and intimidated him
into not telling the truth
about his alien encounter
now obviously
bender had
not been that silenced given that he a
was able to tell grey barker about it
and b
published his own book about it in 1962
in which he explains that
it's not the martians or the venusians
in actual fact he had been taken for a
ride in a flying saucer to the south
pole
by grizzly monster-like aliens from the
planet kazakh wherever that may be
despite
the let's be generous and say skepticism
with which we might greet albert
bender's story
the idea that government agents and
these sinister men in black
are working to hide true information
really gains popularity
and it really takes off going through
the 60s and 70s
and there's an interesting
phenomenon going on with just the men in
black themselves in that quite often
they're
characterized as altogether human agents
of the state
but at the same time they're often given
many inhuman or unearthly
characteristics
characteristics
that very often elide the difference
between these scientific and
supernatural explanations we've been
talking about
and quite often um almost demonic powers
are ascribed to the men in black
walking as though they are not of this
earth not blinking
unnatural powers of persuasion even up
to and including the idea that when they
appear
an odor of sulfur also appears this very
very literal callback to folklore about
demonic
appearance
the fact that traditionally they also
appear in numbers of three
also heavily rooted in kind of mystical
supernatural texts
and it's not just accounts of human
action that take a darker turn as we
move into the 60s
increasingly narratives of alien contact
are going to turn away from friendly
warnings about war
abduction
and experimentation
and that really starts with a couple
from new hampshire betty and barney hill
who
claimed to have been abducted in 1961
although their
story doesn't really receive wide
publicity until 1965.
and the hills abduction is really going
to set the template for all of the
abduction narratives that come after
and looking at the spread of abduction
conspiracism is really interesting
especially if we compare it to kennedy
conspiracism
because like kennedy conspiracism this
is very much a grassroots endeavor and
there's not somebody sitting behind
their desk
saying this is what you all need to
believe is the truth about what's going
on
it's all of these people going out and
trying to uncover the truth themselves
the difference being
that
in terms of abduction conspiracism
they're not detectives they're not going
out looking for evidence right they're
not turning themselves into
experts on bullet trajectories
they themselves
are the evidence their own abduction
experience proves the truth of their
conspiracy
spencer do you feel that these people
are trying to uncover the truth or just
trying to get like book deals because i
feel like everyone is just
like i could make up a story and
turn it into a public affair and get a
lot of publicity from it and like
i don't know do you have any idea what
their motives if they were really trying
to uncover the truth or get some money
or that i mean i think it's um
it's really too complex of a question to
have a single answer to right not least
because
while there are certainly these
criticisms labeled
leveled against abductees or experiences
as they prefer to be called
well there are these accusations that
they're just trying to profit that
they're trying to cash in and sell books
on the other hand
as bridget brown points us to right a
lot of these people who come forward and
say that they've been abducted that is a
socially devastating phenomenon they're
going to get cut off from groups of
friends they're going to be ostracized
they risk being fired from work
so you can benefit from this
but you're really going to have to
benefit from within the world of
ufo abduction conspiracism
matthew
uh the kind of theory of the paranoid
style from hofstetter uh doesn't seem to
be enough to explain these kind of
first-person encounters like we need
you know it's unlike anything we've seen
in any other conspiracies
um
so we need another kind of framework to
understand you know it could be
profit motive or it could be mental
illness that's something that came up in
the reading
and is there kind of a third prong to
that
kind of a different schema through which
we can
approach these people outside of um
they're either crazy or trying to make
money
um
i mean the third prong would be that
they've been abducted by aliens i
suppose right but um
and the problem is we're never really
going to know for sure what their
motivations are in this but you're right
it is this
um
fundamental difference between earlier
conspiracism that we've talked about
where people are
bearing the burden of this conspiracy
themselves it's their own direct
experience
right pearl harbor conspiracists aren't
saying that they flew the plains of
pearl harbor um
kennedy conspiracists aren't saying that
they're the ones that took the shot
all right i shouldn't say that there are
a couple of kennedy conspiracies who do
say they're the ones taking charge um
but this is fundamentally different when
they're saying that they have been
abducted
i think some of that could be a lack of
verifiability
when you claim that it is your own
narrative and that you were in fact
abducted by aliens or what have you
there's no
factual
ground point you know the kennedy
assassination you have x y z happen
those are undisputed you know kennedy
was shot you can't
go too far past that well unless there's
somebody that says kennedy is still
alive right right
or at least it looked like he was
whereas in i feel like in these one of
the rhetorically useful things about
saying that it was your own experience
is that nobody can really
deny that
yeah and that is
at the root of why this uh why ufo
conspiracism can become so expansive
right because we've talked about this
the fact that
in terms of abduction evidence that
evidence is by definition personal it is
by definition subjective
and once we move away from the kind of
objective veracity of physical evidence
what do we get to what have we been
talking about the last couple of classes
distrust of the government
yeah but this kind of wider
issue right we talked about it with tink
thompson
knowing that we can't ever know that it
happened or that it didn't happen so
we're just kind of left with however we
feel like interpreting
the things that we personally were able
to experience good
mary you want to jump on that this
sounds a lot like religion so why are we
so quick to discount ufos when we base
everything on
this word of god and these personal
experiences people in power have had
okay so to the extent that we talk about
um kind of mystical or angelic
visitations why do we accept those but
discount ufo visitations
it's a good question um
some people combine the two some people
say that ufos are angelic visitors um
some people
for scholars tend to say that they're
coming from the same kind of place right
that this
people who are uh saying that they were
abducted now are the people who would
have said that they were visited by
angels several hundred years ago
devon were you gonna i mean one one
troubling thing is the numbers that you
brought up earlier like the 1947 spike
after kenneth arnold when 850 people all
came forward
with alien stories i mean the the
likelihood that these
trends of them all of a sudden being
from venus all of a sudden being from
mars
follow verifiable truth especially when
you can't follow it up with any physical
evidence
i think is uh
somewhat problematic yeah certainly um
and it's inscribed into the name right
as matthew pointed us to before they're
literally called unidentified flying
objects and the problem is that all of
these conspiracies are trying to
inscribe them with meaning are trying to
identify
something that is by definition
unidentified
and so we do reach
that same kind of point of crisis of
knowing as we've been talking about that
epistemological crisis
uh that rumsfeldian mantra that we were
talking about on tuesday right that
there are these known knowns these known
unknowns and those unknown unknowns the
things you don't know that you don't
know
and that's what's going to allow ufo
conspiracism to be so expansive
because once you move away from the
strictures of any physical evidence
pretty much anything is going to get
into play
and pretty much anything is going to
come into play
but still
the fact that there is this wide
latitude of where these conspiracies
could go
the fact that they tend to track within
these trends
would seem to suggest something to us
about how they're being shaped by their
historical context
for example these abduction narratives
the fact that as they are refined and
revised over the following years by
authors like whitley strieber
that they become ever more um
focused on medical experimentation
and increasingly focused on graphic and
explicit sexual violation
and scholars like brown
draw a direct link between the kind of
evolution of these abduction narratives
and
changing anxieties over
sexual and reproductive
sociologies and technologies
the fact that these abduction narratives
start
around the time that new forms of
contraception are coming into play
around the time that new forms of sexual
liberation are coming into play
the fact that increasingly
these abduction narratives focus on
reproductive experimentation
after the roe v wade decision in the 70s
and especially in line with the culture
wars over abortion in the 80s
do you think that like there's a
separation between
people who like
look into this as a sort of like as a
conspiracy or as like an interest versus
like the issue of how it relates to
religion and the fact that it
almost has like a basis in science and
like
like studying like
extraterrestrials are here to study us
they're not here to like
i don't know like save us or like take
us back to their planet or something
like that but they're here to like
in this case like study reproductive
like systems of humans or like
take over your brain or something like
that like is that kind of like the
opposite like to me it seems like kind
of the opposite side of religion because
like
people who look at this kind of can say
that there's a basis of
scientific evidence or scientific maybe
not evidence but like
theory behind it that there is a
rational motive behind why instead of
just like and
like an angel flying through the air
like this is a machine made by beings
who have the intelligence to make a
machine are coming
with like
a motive
to like learn about humans
certainly although
you could make a fairly good argument
that
although they're supernatural angels or
divine providence would usually have had
a rational reason behind why they were
coming into play as well evelyn you want
to jump i thought about the relationship
between the belief in aliens and
religion is that i think that it has to
do with
the
need to believe in something bigger than
yourself and bigger than like what we
have going on here
on earth and i think that a lot of
people who become religious after
something bad has happened is because
they're looking for reassurance or
they are needing to believe that like
everything happens for a reason and i
think that you can apply that logic to
the belief in aliens that like things
that are happening or that people think
they're are happening
are because something else exists
and that phrase there right everything
happens for a reason
we've talked about before as one of
these kind of founding mantras of
conspiracism that everything happens
within a conspiracy for a reason that it
is part of a plan
and in kind of a divine providential
version of that it's happening because
of god's plan
in
a
you know enlightenment rationalist view
of that it's happening because of
a
human or
in this case extraterrestrial agency
that there is a plan that there is
something happening
anna i still think that there's a
difference there because
in terms of like god's plan that is
completely centered around humans
um and like
yeah and like and like earth and if
you're looking at extraterrestrials
you're recognizing that there
is another planet with a community with
a population
of other beings and like other life and
other realities besides just human
reality
i feel like the idea of god
like in god's plan has to do with only a
human reality
so like that would bring in different
kind like
response to like something happening
either looking to god or looking to
aliens would be
two different narratives
nothing uh
yeah i think though you know uh alien
conspiracies
are similar to only like a very
particular type of religion
like uh you know most
religious people
i think are similar to the way most of
us think that or said that we thought
aliens might be out there somewhere past
where we can see
and for religion the past we can see
just happens to be after death not
outside the range of our telescopes
um the alien conspiracies we've talked
about
are more similar to like the
premillennialists that we discussed
before
where you know it starts extending into
where we can see or we ought to be able
to see if this conspiracy weren't you
know muddying the waters or obscuring
things
yeah and there are um
as we hopefully will get to we'll see um
there are people who make an explicit
connection there as well there is an um
there are those who make a explicit
linkage between
this uh evangelical pre-millennial
dispensationalism and extraterrestrials
usually folding extraterrestrials in as
agents of satan as agents of the
antichrist within those kind of
prophecies
and these are these are interesting
questions and they're big questions um
that unfortunately i don't think we're
gonna be able to answer today um
but that relationship between
uh extraterrestrial visitation and
supernatural religious visitation
is intimately intertwined
and these supernatural elements these
other worldly elements are key parts of
these abduction narratives these alien
narratives
but it's not just
religious narratives that are playing
into this as well right um these
narratives have strong elements of
native american captivity narratives
from the 17th 18th centuries right
fears of white colonists particularly of
white female colonists being abducted
and held captive by native americans
[Music]
in terms of their kind of sexual content
they're the almost pornographic detail
that these abduction narratives go into
there's a significant rhetorical debt
owed to
the anti-catholic escaped nun narratives
of the 19th early 20th centuries
some of which we saw
advertised in those clan newspapers that
we were looking at right
so there's a lot of different elements
coming into this
not just sexual anxiety as well anxiety
is about race
the fact that the first abducted couple
is an interracial couple
is not unrelated
the fact that
one of the major fears in the 60s
as
um interracial marriage is ruled legal
by the supreme court
the fact that this these fears of
miscegenation are very very present
even as
alien abduction stories present new
fears of interspecies sex
those are not unrelated elements
and you have this kind of really
interesting
conflation
as brown points to between the kind of
individual body of
the abductee of the experiencer
and of the national body of the
citizenry as a whole who is being
violated by this conspiracy
and it is increasingly a conspiracy it
is something in which
the government is complicit in
um
it's also worth talking just very
briefly
related to that question of race um
there's a really odd kind of eugenicist
element that plays into
alien uh abduction theories coming out
through the 70s 80s 90s as well
and whilst there's this kind of huge
taxonomy of alien races that gets
constructed there's really kind of three
key races races species what are we
going to call them
one of which is the pleiadians
who are described as benevolent and
loving
and beautiful
and highly evolved and spiritual
anybody want to guess what
the pleiadians are meant to look like
caucasians any specific kind of
caucasians
blonde blue-eyed right they are
incredibly aryan um in fact they are
commonly refer referred to as tall
nordics
nordic itself
being a term of eugenicist taxonomy
coming out of the early 20th century
as opposed to you know
those lower class southern europeans who
can't be counted as being as racially
superior as the nordics
and you see
the short gray
as the kind of um
equivalent of southern europeans to some
extent in this taxonomy
the short gray
whose description owes a debt to those
little green men read to the movies of
the 50s to frank scully
explanations
but
whose popular appearance culture is
really cemented by betty and barney hill
again right not only do they set the
template for the abduction narrative
they set the idea of what the big headed
gray alien with the big eyes looks like
and really cements that within the
popular consciousness
the other big kind of grouping of
alien species within these taxonomies
are our old friends the reptilians
or um to give them their
ufo conspiracy name the draconians
who are
these tall lizard people who are
probably hiding amongst us plotting to
take over the earth at any time
uh anybody remember
the english conspiracist we've talked
about before who's particularly focused
in on
these conspiracists i'm particularly
focusing on these reptilians
anna i don't remember that but i did
read something recently okay that popped
up
saying that someone had seen
justin bieber
turning into his reptilian form in the
airport
a few weeks ago
he is a secret
uh
giant lizard that he is also one of them
yes yeah which
i had never heard before very talented
well lots of people are everywhere
matthew we can't discount this um
especially if you ask david ike right
here's the english conspiracist that we
talked about on our very first day of
class
who is
thoroughly an advocate of the idea that
the lizard people are
the queen the president
virtually everybody in high office
uh
anybody remember what ike thinks that
they do
how do they survive
they drink the blood of
blonde people basically right they drink
blood they don't just drink blood they
drink the blood of blonde eyed
blonde
blue-eyed blond-haired children of these
aryan children right
so again there are they are this
specific racial threat um
and
containing these kind of deep elements
of anti-semitic blood libel myths as
well
sergio are you know yeah i was gonna ask
is there a
i wouldn't i don't know if it's a
conspiracy theory but a theory on
since they're described as
draconians feeding on aryan like
children
would it also be that they were feeding
on
plutons padilla children
um
looking children are children's
oblivions
well
all right now we're getting into the
deep weeds
depending on who you ask the palladians
and the draconians may be working
together in conjunction with the secret
rulers of the state
on the other hand they may be engaged in
a secret millennia-long war
um
on the other hand we may be the
descendants of the pledians
on the other hand the reptilians may
have traveled back in time to create us
to create a food source for themselves
uh which is to say virtually any answer
is possible to your question because as
we've established right with this
epistemological crisis with this divorce
from physical evidence
virtually any conspiracy theory is
possible
and those conspiracy theories are
increasingly going to make the
government complicit
and an excellent example of that is
roswell
allegedly flying saucer crashes in
roswell in
july 1947
right on trend with our other ufo
sightings
and because it's surrounded by this
wealth of other ufo sightings and
because
the air force pretty quickly declares
the wreckage that's found in roswell to
be that of a weather balloon
the media moves on there are hundreds
more ufo sightings to report on
and it's not until
the boom in ufo conspiracism coming out
of the late 1970s
that roswell really regains attention in
conspiracist circles
so we talked about this a little bit on
tuesday why might we see a boom in
conspiracism and it's particularly
anti-government conspiracism in the late
70s
marissa
and then you have the revelation of um
co-intel pro chaos and there's all these
things that are coming out the church
committee
so it's just a lot of like
operations that the public didn't know
about that are now in the public
good right we've got watergate we've got
the church committee all these
revelations of cia misdeeds mk ultra
um right lending even more credence to
the idea of secret medical
experimentation going on
and there is a very kind of explicit
linkage being made in the late 70s
between this post-watergate era and a
boom in uh alien conspiracism and
particularly abduction conspiracism
you see the establishment of citizens
against ufo secrecy in 1977 an
organization dedicated to using freedom
of information act requests
to get the government to reveal the
truth about ufos which is almost
beautifully naive right the fact that
you think the government is planning
this huge conspiracy but
that because the law is on your side you
can still get them to reveal those
secrets it's a really nice sentiment i
always find
but not only does citizens against ufo
secrecy come along
but a
nuclear physicist turned ufologist
called stanton friedman rediscovers
roswell
and we don't want to draw kind of overly
simplistic links between this
post-watergate um
national
concern
and this boom in roswell conspiracism
but sometimes the researchers themselves
make that subtext text
stanton friedman explicitly says roswell
is a cosmic watergate
right
other rival researchers like don schmidt
describe the kennedy assassination as a
formative experience
and compare
the government statements on roswell to
the warren commission report and in
neither case can this official document
be trusted
philip corso who writes the really
popular the day after roswell is a firm
advocate of the two oswalds theory of
the kennedy assassination
and goes further than that to say that
the entire cold war was really just a
cover to help develop anti-alien defense
mechanisms
and you see this
flood of roswell literature through the
80s
through the 90s
that
says yes the government covered it up
and they didn't do it for our own good
donald kehoe was wrong
instead it is a litany of misinformation
and misdeeds
no longer is the air force this benign
body trying to protect
the public from national hysteria now
president truman sets up magic 12 in
1947
as a special government body to cover up
the truth about ufos
presumably also in charge of those men
in
black and this reaches kind of such a
crisis point that in 1994
the air force actually releases a report
about roswell a thousand pages long
and you can still find this as i pulled
it off for today on the dod website this
is still
very easily publicly available
and the air force says
okay
actually we did lie to you about it
being
a weather balloon in actual fact it's
the wreckage from project mogul
which was a top secret project to try to
detect long-range
soviet nuclear
experiments
so that's good right that comes out all
of the roswell conspiracy theorists say
brilliant now it's cleared up we can
move on no
no it doesn't tend to work that way the
government coming out and saying that
we've been lying to you for almost 50
years but now we're telling you the
truth doesn't convince an awful lot of
these conspiracy theorists
in much the same way that the pearl
harbor inquiry just spurs more
conspiracy theories in much the same way
that the warren commission just spurs
more conspiracy theories the air force's
roswell report just spurs more
conspiracy theories it's not helped by
the cia also coming out in 1997 and
saying
we've also been lying to you and we lied
to you about the ufo sightings you did
see stuff but it was top secret military
planes and we couldn't tell you sorry
but ufos still aren't real
we didn't have exactly the same impact
um
saying that you've been lying for years
is not going to build public uh trust
that you're now telling the truth
and so
over this kind of course of the 80s and
90s as this roswell conspiracism
specifically develops and this abduction
conspiracism more generally develops you
really see it move into
not mainstream acceptance but mainstream
recognition
right nobody came to class today never
having heard of roswell nobody came to
class today having never seen a picture
of a short grey alien with a big head
and big eyes
and it's really
very um
strongly at the forefront of popular
consciousness in the 90s and you get
best-selling paperbacks that get turned
into high-rated tv shows right the truth
about roswell gets turned into a
showtime show
you get the classic tabloid covers
weekly world news is all over the
clinton alien relationship in the 90s um
there is even at some point intimations
that bill clinton has another sex
scandal but this time with an
extraterrestrial intern
and of course television right there's a
reason why the x-files comes along in
the 90s because it is the kind of pop
cultural culmination of a lot of these
trends that we've been talking about
and the fact that these trends become
so
prominent within mainstream discourse
is also going to open up room at the
fringes for even more esoteric
conspiracies to develop matthew
um
scully from the x-files is that a
throwback to uh scully who the
true magazine yeah yes
very much so yeah
um
there's a lot of kind of these
references back in this the the creators
of the x-files are very well steeped in
this law when they come along
also very well steeped in this law
are people like william cooper
who releases behold a pale horse
in 1991
and behold a pale horse is a really odd
book in many ways
not least the fact that cooper doesn't
just believe virtually every conspiracy
theory we've talked about today he
believes virtually every conspiracy
theory we've talked about all semester
and because
if you believe in a conspiracy that
conspiracy is in this book
it makes the book
very very popular and very very
influential among conspiracist circles
um and amongst a wide variety of
conspiracist circles
right uh
cooper's book is popular with the
patriot or militia movement in the 90s
timothy mcveigh is a fan of beholder
pale horse
but also it's really popular in the hip
hop fan community and the idea that you
know jay-z is an illuminati
mastermind these kind of very disparate
communities unite behind
holding william cooper's beholder pale
horse in high regard
and part of that is
how all encompassing
cooper's narrative is
and it has to be all-encompassing
because he has a very
direct philosophy
as he writes
i do not believe in fate
i do not believe in accidents
i cannot and will not
accept the theory that long sequences of
unrelated accidents determine world
events
remind us of anything
bingo
cooper is a
excellent example
of that idea of mechanistic causality of
that idea that evelyn brought up before
right that there has to be a reason
for cooper
everything happens for a reason there is
no contingency there is no accident
which means that
when the question of extraterrestrial
life comes along
it also is going to have to be folded
into his grand conspiracist narrative
and cooper's
bete noir
as with a lot of modern conspiracists is
the bilderberg group
right that shadowy group that supposedly
convenes once a year and is the secret
puppet masters council of the world
um
listen to
alex jones for more than about 10
minutes on any given day and it's almost
a guarantee you're going to get to the
bilderberg group pretty quickly um
very much a foundational element of the
kind of new world order conspiracism
that takes hold in the 90s
and cooper's a key player in that
for cooper
the bilderberg group is founded in 1947.
why what's happening in 1947
the manhattan project is mostly done by
that point uh
the year of the roswell crunch year of
the roswell crash year of all of the ufo
sightings right
for cooper the bilderberg group is
created in direct reaction to the
extraterrestrial uh threat
for cooper though
magic 12 isn't created to cover up the
truth about ufos he says that friedman
and others like him are actually
government disinformation agents
in fact what he says is majesty 12
is created to establish relations
with these aliens
and cooper goes further he says that by
1954
president eisenhower is going to sign a
treaty with the aliens
that says
look
you want to come along and
experiment on humans that's fine we'll
look the other way
we'll even build secret bases for you to
do so like area 51
but in return
we want
secret advanced technologies
the two most commonly pointed to being
beam weapons and time travel
which apparently the u.s has had hold of
since 1954 so
what they're doing with it i don't know
but apparently they do have it
in case anybody's wondering according to
cooper the alien ambassador's name is
his most on omnipotent highness krill um
so even in alien ambassadorships the
patriarchy still holds sway apparently
and only one u.s president according to
cooper is willing to challenge
this threatening alliance with the
aliens anyone who wants to take guesses
to which heroic president is willing to
stand up to this
jfk of course jfk
once again
we see conspiracists inscribing the
kennedy death with its own meaning
again a form of counter factual history
coming into play
whereas oliver stone's counterfactual
history says that if kennedy had lived
he'd have pulled us out of vietnam
cooper's counterfactual history says
that if you'd lived he would have
revealed the truth about the aliens
and also about the fact that the cia
controls the world drug markets to fund
the secret alliance with the aliens
and also the fact that
eisenhower was actually working for
rockefeller who was actually part of the
council on foreign relations who was
actually working for the illuminati
which was actually part of the
bilderberg group
and working in conjunction
with
european royalists and as always the
catholics
um
anna so are there thoughts that
aliens are behind jfk's assassination to
keep it quiet
very much so um
if you take uh cooper's telling
then
he may have been alien he may have been
human but either way it's the driver of
kennedy's car who actually kills kennedy
and does so in order to silence him on
this question of the alien conspiracy
as you might tell from that
there's a kind of heavily religious
element here as well right the
anti-catholic element because where's he
getting behold a pale horse from
from revelations
good
again he's strongly fitting in as
matthew pointed us to earlier within
this um
strain of
pre-millennial dispensationalist
apocalypticism he is one of those who
strongly believe that aliens are
probably satanic agents
and are playing their own part in
bringing about the end times
he also folds in ideas of medical and
eugenic conspiracism
um going back to evelyn's question as to
why why are the aliens taking us why are
they uh experimenting on us cooper's
argument is that
aliens genetic structure is
deteriorating and they need to
experiment on our superior genetic
structure
in order to save their the alien race
which is a really interesting turnabout
right where you say
these
beings from another planet who've
traveled however far to get here are
still racially inferior to us
there's a weird racial supremacism at
work there
that in some way
echoes the kinds of racial supremacism
we saw with pearl harbor that we saw
with the loss of china
the idea that america couldn't possibly
have lost to these inferior races
instead there must be complicity from
within that allows this conspiracy to
take hold allows america to be handed
this defeat
so cooper very much operating within
those strains as well
and while we roll our eyes as i think
we've all rolled our eyes talking about
cooper he is massively influential not
least in
new world order militia conspiracism
and we talked about the fact it's no
coincidence that abduction narratives
coincide with new
reproductive
technological and social anxieties it's
no coincidence that cooper and
new world order conspiracism
both emerge in the 90s
and there is a strong linkage between
the two
and that's not to say that the two forms
of conspiracism map perfectly onto each
other
but
a lot of the tropes that we see in new
world order conspiracism
the men in black the black helicopters
the secret bases
these are all tropes that are drawn from
ufo conspiracism and william cooper is
really one of the key linkages there
giving birth to this new
form of um
extraterrestrial conspiracism that we
seem to be working our way through now
because if you know anybody has noticed
not a lot of people are talking about
alien abduction anymore and alien
reduction narratives have kind of fallen
off it seems to have been a late 20th
century phenomenon rather than an early
21st century phenomenon and instead as
bridget brown points us to we're more
and more seeing the dark side hypothesis
in play these new fears of an alien
human alliance
that is
deeply reflective of contemporary fears
of terrorism of state sovereignty
and of the national security state
all right unfortunately we are out of
time so we will leave it there we're
going to pick up with some of these
threads on tuesday particularly these
ideas about structures of race and
conspiracism so have a good weekend i
will see you then
[Music]